we'd been told to come to the junction
of Kensington and Allegheny
he'd been warned that we would meet
people in the lowest moment of their
lives
and under the train line in the cold and
the wind
in this Northern suburb of one of
America's great cities there they were
[Music]
it's grim
it's uncomfortable to see
to film
but then it is the reality here
[Music]
and it isn't just a story about
addiction as if that wasn't enough
because on the Streets of Philadelphia
it's about something new a substance
that is being cut by dealers into the
drug Supply and it's having the most
devastating impact
came and it just
it got worser and worser would you mind
if I ask how long you've been using for
like the last 10 years
but these wounds are something new yes
very known
like six months no
the wound is a consequence of a
devastating new twist in America's drug
epidemic thank you so much guys because
the substances he's addicted to are now
mixed by dealers see you on Saturday
come see me okay with something that's
rotting his skin
it's called xylazine or tranq an animal
tranquilizer cut with America's street
drug of the moment fentanyl itself
utterly awful
it's volunteers who treat the wounds
where they find them it's gonna be on
his leg Doctors Hospitals have no
protocols for this in the worst cases
they are amputating limbs is this
something new
started and appears nine months
on these streets they're learning as
they go
and almost everyone here seems to have
the wounds
Sam is just 28.
these are not injection site wounds like
these are all wounds like other than
injection citing this is kind of a
common presentation that we've seen with
these types of wounds with like with the
the Fentanyl and train is that these
kind of like random bus rules and then
they just they kind of erode through the
skin really rapidly so like you're
probably fine one day and then all of a
sudden days were there right
yeah Sam's story is such an insight into
the stigmatized world of suffering and
addiction
have not been able to detox off the
tracks successfully it's just every time
I get to day 10 and I'm still
withdrawing
um
[Music]
every day that I'm out here longer it's
another piece
um you know my values my soul my essence
of who I am is getting lost you get what
I'm saying so it's like how much can you
take and then you see these people here
that are just a shell there's just
nothing there anymore you just and you
know that
you know they are living two minutes at
a time of their life like just to get
that use and that's all that matters and
I'm so lucky that there's still more of
me left and it's literally decimating
the American Youth you know it's just
the uh quiet killer going on right now
you saw here but this is not a
neighborhood that could ever be
described as pleased it's beyond the
control of law enforcement
and so our Guides Through Kensington are
Ronnie and Dawn what's going on with
your leg both in recovery from addiction
Angels In Motion is their charity here's
another water for you and from our time
with them it's so clear that for the
people here they truly are angels
I've been to more funerals than you than
you know
um because you get to know these people
so well yes and like I have their
pictures in my phone their cell phones
because I've treated you know I've
helped them out so much and then they've
passed away and I can't get rid of the
phone number and all that want a snack
bag
is that all your hair
it's gorgeous
stay safe okay
there you go
[Music]
Ronnie and Dawn wanted to take us to an
underpass it was cleared by the city
authorities a few years back but the
people moved on had nowhere to go hi
need a snack bag and Beyond the common
struggle here each story on each street
corner is particular Zach's path here
began in Iraq thanks so much you're
welcome he's a veteran this place eats
everything and anything that is good
I need probably to be arrested
either put in jail I need to go to detox
and Rehab somewhere far away
I just need to get out of here
[Music]
our brain tells us to breathe
their brain tells them to breathe and
get drugs or you will die like that's
the kind of maybe not those exact words
but like that's the feeling that they
have if I don't have this I'm going to
die I'm going to be so sick
and like if it was easy we wouldn't have
this problem
around the corner this cruel
otherworldiness is strangely compounded
the music is supposed to deter
homelessness
of course it doesn't and so to a
classical soundtrack we meet Danielle
right now like there's like barely any
fennel in it so like as you go through
withdrawal faster
dealers add the trunk to bulk the supply
it increases their margins it also makes
the withdrawals so much more intense
I was banging my
[Music]
mind is really that bad
this is so bad
the worst I
I've ever felt in my entire life some of
those we met here wanted us to show
their faces with others we've agreed not
to
right here and it like goes it's like
trying to come out my skin so you're
shooting on on one side but but the the
injury is on the other side as a result
of the the drug Danielle is a mum of
three young boys
today I was crying all day I don't know
what to do
I really don't
you know this is a story that could
simply be told through the shock of the
images but it is so much deeper than
that it reflects systemic problems
access to addiction treatment Mental
Health Care housing health insurance
what we've seen here the people we've
got to know their story is one of
fundamental American failure
we asked to speak to the city's mayor he
was not available but in an office
overlooking Kensington Dr Andrew best is
the city director for substance use
prevention
but as of as of right now there's no you
know state or federal funding available
to mitigate some of the challenges with
xylazine this is the Forefront of a new
crisis yes yes I would definitely agree
um we've definitely already have you
know been contacted by different cities
we've met with other cities just to talk
about our our experiences big challenge
it is a challenge yes
America is so often defined by two words
hope and opportunity
and yet on these streets
we found so little of either
Mark Stone Sky News in Philadelphia